how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk all things marvel
and a happy halloween to everybody i
hope everybody's dressing up as some
super cool things i hope there's a lot
of cool superhero costumes out there and
i hope everybody's going to be safe
tonight
and for your halloween video today of
course we're going to be talking about
spider-man 3 yet again because
tom holland has the script for
spider-man 3.
and now jacob battle on and zendaya have
landed in atlanta they're on set now and
jacob bottellon
has the script and has shared his
reaction to him
reading some of it and it is quite the
reaction and it gets everybody even more
excited for spider-man 3. so let's take
a look at this
and we even have the video of tom
holland getting his script as well if
you haven't seen that yet but real quick
if you love gaming be sure to check out
chaos gaming for all of your latest
gaming videos and some awesome
giveaways that he does as well and
subscribe to my channel for a chance to
win this week's giveaway which is a
spider-man
imposter funko pop so let's take a look
at jacob's or
ned's reaction to the spider-man 3
script that he just got and is reading
for the first time
no short and sweet but
it makes you wonder what exactly did he
just read
now we could guess and theorize what he
read pretty much up until the movie
would come out but there's just no real
way of knowing
however in a movie where the
spider-verse and the multiverse exist
you kind of have to wonder if he's
reacting at maybe an alternate version
of himself perhaps maybe even
a hobgoblin this is something that fans
have been wondering for a couple of
movies now whether or not ned is going
to become the hobgoblin
especially because spider-man far from
home did tease the comic aspect of ned
and betty's relationship now i don't
think ned will actually betray peter and
become hobgoblin in the main mcu
timeline but again
in the multiverse he could see that
version of himself or perhaps he's
simply reacting to toby mcguire andrew
garfield and a miles morales showing up
but one thing is for sure is that he was
super excited and super
surprised by what he read which i think
we're all going to be pretty surprised
with spider-man 3 when it finally comes
out based off of
all these insanely awesome things that
we've heard and tom holland has had the
script for a few days now and i'm
surprised he hasn't spoiled anything yet
so i just got home and uh i'm in atlanta
just been delivered a package that
package is an ipad
and on that ipad is a script this
pillow's doing what nothing
and that script is spider-man 3
so i'm about to find out what i'm going
to be doing for the next five months
i'm not going to tell you anything about
it because i've learned my lesson
but um i'm serious oh
[ __ ] what this ipad
um okay i'm going to read this now and i
can't wait
and i'll speak to you so i hope
everybody has a good halloween today be
safe and be sure to subscribe to my
channel so you don't miss out on any of
the latest
mcu and spider-man 3 news be sure to
like the video and don't forget to
follow me on instagram and twitter if
you want live updates
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
you